[Music]
the universal classic horror films were
the ones that really grabbed me you know
the Wolfman Frankenstein brighter
Frankenstein Dracula and again we all
saw them on television and you know I
mean so many of us you know like he said
kids of the 50s that's where we were
exposed to that stuff and then Famous
Monsters of Filmland came out and and
and that you know that's where I learned
that people you know did this for a
living and I said well that's what I
want to do oh it's cooler than that
when he was a kid he wanted to be a
doctor he wanted to be dr. Frankenstein
and create monsters no seriously
and then what changed doctors didn't
make monsters he took I wasn't til is
about ten years old and it was a pretty
stupid kid I guess yeah and and then I
dinner realized like he said you know
Famous Monsters said Famous Monsters he
went wait a minute makeup men make
monsters John Landis is the one that
really got me interested in this genre I
was more into dramas and musicals
because of the stuff my dad shot but
John is the one that really got me to
focus in on this you know it's a real
tribute to it's so nice to see so many
people here you know to watch the the
screening him can't wait to see him Rick
and George read my screenplay for an
American Werewolf in London in 1971 when
we made schlock I had written it in 1969
in the former Yugoslavia I was a schlep
Iran a movie called Kelly's heroes and
I'd written it then and it actually got
me work as a writer I got the James Bond
job because cubby broccoli on the Spy
Who Loved Me Love that script and I said
I want to produce it he'll know it's
weird but that's how I got the job as a
writer anyway but no one would make it
they just thought it was too odd but I
had this very specific metamorphosis in
mind and a four-legged wolf it really
works and I think really the main reason
were
are sitting I'm in the middle here is
because David Naughton and Griffin and
Jenny Agutter and John would fine I had
a wonderful cast and he really makes
they and Rick Rick Baker they really
made it work
I really felt strongly for I may have
been wrong but I felt strongly I didn't
want famous actors I wanted to use as
unknown as possible and everyone knows
that David well you had a TV series and
hit songs and he was the dr. pepper guy
and honestly he was well honestly I when
I saw those commercials Melvin zukovsky
because when I saw those commercials do
you remember he would be dancing and
singing I thought you know this is such
a stupid commercial and he is so winning
you really like him and that's why I
wanted to meet him honestly I've wanted
to see you for that and because you
really have to like David he asked you
know what would it take to do this and
what what you know I want this to be the
really cool and I want it to be done the
best way it could be done what would it
take and I said you know time and money
you know I mean at that point you know
schlock you know we had very little
money and very little time to make this
stuff and that's the way it films were
that at the time and he said okay what
do you need nice oh well if I could get
like six months it's like you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars I could
do some really cool stuff instead of you
know thousand dollars in six weeks you
know and and he he let me do that the
bravest thing in George was my ally in
this the bravest thing we did is we
didn't have a deal on them we had didn't
have a greenlit movie we do because we
made a negative pick up with Polygram
pictures but we hadn't made the deal and
I wanted to shoot that winter and we
actually hired David and Griffin and
made their deals and we didn't have a
movie to bring them out now we'll now
I'll tell you now you tell me
when as soon as John said okay you're
gonna play this part of David go right
over to Rick Baker's shop which I drove
over went over to introduce myself to
John to to Rick and his group of young
guys who was we found out we're making
their first horror film as well and Rick
said which role you're playing and I
said I'm playing David because I feel
sorry for you
it is sort of tiring spending all day
getting made up then you have to perform
and that was one of the that was the
challenge for me the whole film had been
wrapped I knew where I was at this point
you know when this transformation is
going to come because we've shot
everything else but it was really a
matter of how you know how are we gonna
do this I'm gonna do it over the top and
I really couldn't go over the top for
John it seemed so there weren't any time
he says okay bring it back you know
bring that in it's not that painful or
or any of that stuff it was just go for
broke and maybe we'll be done for the
day
so we'll get to do it again tomorrow